okay good evening my name is captain
kirkmore with the city of henderson
police department
i'm here to provide an initial briefing
on an officer-involved shooting that
occurred here in the city
of henderson today on january 11th at
approximately 8 50 p.m
this is the first officer involved
shooting for 2021.
the information i'm about to provide is
very preliminary the information can
change as the investigation continues so
please keep that in mind
what we know at this moment moment is
the following
henderson property detectives along with
marked patrol units were conducting a
surveillance operation
on a known armed burglary suspect
the decision was made to stop the
suspect after
some continued surveillance over at the
1011 stuffel beam here at the
steward center when they attempted to
stop the suspect
the suspect fled a foot pursuit ensued
during the foot pursuit the suspect
produced a firearm to which an
officer-involved shooting occurred
officers initially performed life-saving
measures on the individual who was
transported to a local hospital and is
in stable condition
there was only one other officer injury
related to the foot pursuit
and that's all the information i have at
this time i'll take a few questions
yes so he's a suspect in a significant
amount of cases here in the city of
henderson
regarding armed burglaries
i do not have that information at this
time we will provide it once
the time has elapsed
that is i can't confirm but it's
believed that he was hit only one time
just about the work that went into the
investigation just catching that
burglary suspect
i can't go into detail of how but
they've done some outstanding work uh
obviously property crime has been a
focus here in the city of henderson
we've been working very diligently and
hard and putting the
uh correct resources to curb this trend
you know in our community
this was one of the individuals that was
high on our priority list
and we were able to surveil them and you
know and make the arrests so
this should have a very favorable
outcome
not no there's a small injury but it was
related to something else
no no gunshots no how many officers
just one and just one time
yes just one shot okay
no this is he we were doing the
surveillance and they picked this spot
when he came to this spot as a good
place to stop him doing that they were
seeing that there were not many people
here so that's a good spot to
conduct an operation like this yes they
were
they were conducting a surveillance
operation
okay